vamos olhar um pouquinho a essa essa
seqüência de fractais na nossa vida
inclusive aparece o dia a dia na nossa
vida nós estamos diante de fractais de
todos vocês certamente já produziram um
fractal ao longo das nossas vidas
daqui a pouco nós temos aí fractal
natureza um bloco e romanesca uma couve
flor é um facto tal que significa isso
que o todo é semelhante à parte
cada uma daqueles com nezinho semelhante
ao todo então um fractal no fundo é uma
seqüência de objetos que são altos
similares em escalas diferentes uma
árvore também um com mão uma poncha são
todas as estruturas que são formadas por
partes altas similares uma das outras
então nós temos ali do lado esquerdo com
o famoso desenho do oeste é já um pintor
famoso holandês não ele fez várias
pinturas muito interessantes e aqui
esculturas fractais também um pouco a
propaganda do meu filho ele ele gosta de
fractais também não então tem cultura
secretário toda a espuma não é essa
posição sentado ainda tem uma estrutura
fractal
há atualmente essas estruturas espaciais
não é que estão sendo desenvolvidas para
a construção civil também e
principalmente nas áreas biológicas
biomedicina com aqui nessa universidade
tem um curso de biomedicina é
extremamente importante é uma pele
artificial e uma das das condições
principais de uma pele artificial ser
eficiente é que ela tenha a mesma
estrutura fraxe fractal do que a nossa
própria pele quando se projeta uma
membrana biológica ela tem que ter essa
mesma e futura fractal que significa
isso a mesma geometria o mesmo tipo de
geometria isso aqui por exemplo é o que
eu estava dizendo que todos vocês
fizeram para que tal eu vou produzir
fractal para vocês aqui agora
vivo então pra talvez entender melhor o
que estou falando
eu vou perguntar pra vocês se isso aqui
o que é
é um plano uma linha o volume uma
superfície é um plano né
duas dimensões certo são duas menções
agora eu vou fazer isso como você já
deve ter feito várias vezes onde fizeram
coisas que não gostaram
aí eu pergunto pra vocês o que que é
isso que está aqui é um volume
isso é compacto como o volume é um plano
é um fraque tal não é nem três dimensões
não é nem duas dimensões é alguma coisa
que está entre 2 e 3 de dezembro
aqui nós vamos obter com várias
pedacinhos então é isso
então todo mundo já fez fractais a gente
faz fractais várias vezes durante a
nossa vida
quais são os clássicos que fractais que
a gente conhece do ponto de vista mais
analítico são chamadas de có são
produzidas a partir de um gerador que
aquela chapeuzinho segundo lugar 6
observarem aquele gerador que aquele
segundo desenho se ele é reduzido para
ficar o similar colocado em cima dos
outros e vão reproduzido o figuras que
cada vez são mais complexos mas sempre
similares anterior e ácido a direito
não sei acho que muita gente falar são o
conjunto foi quem por ali
as estruturas fractais tem figuras
belíssimas como nós vamos ver daqui a
pouco
então essas são as grandes os dois
grandes clássicos um pouco resumidamente
essas curvas de corp
esses conjuntos de manter o bom isso
então é uma idéia que há surgiu foi
desenvolvido a partir da manhã o broto
que popularizou no essa estrutura para
tal nem deu muita inclusive com a parte
computacional o s house dó que
desenvolveu parte matemático marcelo
barros que trabalhou muito nessa parte
dinâmica não é e com essa parte dinâmica
o que acontece é o seguinte foi
associado tempo portanto períodos não é
com geometrias quando a gente pensa em
associar períodos de digamos alguns
estão de algum instrumento de alguma ao
elemento como foi esse fractal
o músico olhou e disse bom vocês estão
trabalhando em frequências isso é música
então os fractais cantam e de fato eles
canto
então surgiu mais um elemento no nesse
contexto todo que é a música e de fato
eu vou aí
como já comentei cada uma dessas dessas
figurinhas que estão aí tem uma
geometria diferente tem uma freqüência
uma distribuição de freqüência diferente
então
esse é um deles
o outro e outro
então mesmo intervalo não é tocado por
tratar diferente agora quero que vocês
descubram que música é essa tocada pela
primeira frota planta lá alguém
descobriu não mas esse é o que é a
sequência de de freqüência na com a
mesma razão para aquela falta do meio
alguém já descobriu não agora outra
agora descobriu né quer dizer é a mesma
referência mesmo mês - intervalo tocado
por três instrumentos diferentes não tem
gente interessada em desenvolver esses
para hospitais que são próprias para tal
modo que existem técnicas e teorias que
às vezes parecem muito complicadas mas
de um ponto de vista e encontra um
caminho muito mais fáceis não muito mais
a acessíveis nem mais ricos
utilizando outro tipo de técnica
mostrando aí agora o que é essa
só uma coisa para a qual pode fazer isso
significa se nós tivermos nessa caixa e
colocar dentro uma linha com comprimento
impune tu só se ela for com uma
estrutura pra tal cada pedacinho sendo
algo semelhante a outro nós continuamos
conseguimos ter essa essa linha com o
complemento infinito não é essa aí é uma
figura do tipo do manoel broto não é é
uma noção do infinito que a lei só
entende pra própria infinito
agora porque fractal é tão importante
porque nós aliás nós estamos diante de
um ano na vida em todos os momentos da
nossa vida da gente encontra fractais
essas estruturas são altas similares e
eu disse que ela tão importante que está
na origem da nossa própria a existência
como a humanidade na pelo menos aqueles
que pertencem às religiões monoteístas
não é porque deus criou o homem a quem a
sua imagem e semelhança que nós somos 11
uma estrutura fractal do próprio deus
agora passe nação é uma música né agora
quero interromper um pouco isso na e
partir para uma outra
outro ponto que me preocupo com a multa
que é a essa atitude que a gente tem
perante a vida
isso é cultural que nós vemos aqui
várias apresentações
excelente né e todas elas demonstraram
coragem diante da vida diante dos
problemas e nós precisamos ter só com
isso não é muito comum na nossa
sociedade e eu queria que isso fosse a
preocupação de todos nós precisamos
mudar também essa nossa cultura de forma
que a gente possa ter mais esperança a
olhar o futuro com muito mais coragem e
isso se reflete essa nossa nosso tipo de
certo receio de enfrentar a vida
apenas receio mas um pessimismo diante
do futuro a gente não pode ser assim
isso se reflete em tudo você
provavelmente conhece essa música no
fascinação a música de 1932 muito bonita
que foi criada a melodia só sem letra
então aí a letra u brasil
o brasileiro é o sonho de conhecer a
letra americano o que vocês podem
observar essas duas vezes
aqui começa tudo muito bonito sonhos
sonhos e quimeras mil e acaba uma droga
tudo perdido mentira tudo ruim aqui
começa
pode ser que não dê certo viu quem sabe
vamos tentar no final dá certo
então é um pouco isso que a gente tem
que olhar vai dar certo é preciso ter
coragem de enfrentar essa é esse o nosso
problema com uma expectativa de otimista
mesmo que hajam pedras pelo caminho que
temos vários depoimentos que houve
pedras pelo caminho foram superadas
então isso acho que é importante isso
fica refletido até na nossa cultura não
queria que vocês agora esconder que
inventou os fractais cantando essa
música dos fractais foi o manuel broto
foi o barros foi ocorre ou foi raúl sohr
quem aposta no meu brother
quem aposta no barros e aposta no
corre-corre está tendo a maioria talvez
quem aposta no riazor ao software
metalurgia foi o barro não foi quem
mandou broto nem corre foi barros
então a gente acreditar na gente mesmo é
aquela que é um pouco resultado da
arquiteta exercício anterior
na a gente não acredita na gente né é
preciso que a gente acredita
nós podemos não é aqui também nove
podemos na então é essa é a mensagem que
eu queria deixar com vocês nós vivemos
numa onda de choque cultural como gente
tem eu tenho sempre reforçar essa idéia
as coisas andam muito mais depressa nem
a ciência e tecnologia nossa vida muito
mais depressa e nós vivemos nessa onda
de choque cultural
e essa onde de choctaw nos obriga a
surfar
não adianta nadar em águas calmas a
gente nada temos tempo para pensar agora
não temos muito tempo para pensar
nós temos que reagir às situações e
precisam de uma prancha para surfar
então a gente precisa de auxílio bom
essa mensagem que queria andar pra vocês
não é que idéias surgem idéias são a
recolhidas diversos a partir de diversas
áreas do conhecimento e formam um
conjunto novo e vamos pensar sempre me
soltei escocês podem todos nós podemos a
partir da reunião de vários
conhecimentos abrir novas janelas para o
e coragem porque nós somos muito bons